- I'm Robin.
- Pleasure to meet you.
Is he here?
- Is who here?
(pirate music)
- Henderson.
(laughing)
Henderson.
He's back, he's back.
- I'm back.
- You got the job!
- I got the job!
(laughing)
(mimicking trumpet)
(slower trumpet mimicking)
Hey!
(fake fighting)
(laughing)
- How many children are you friends with?
- [Judgemental Voice] Boom!
And another one bites the dust.
You are oh for six, Popeye.
- Yeah, yeah, I can count.
- You know that means you suck.
- Yup, I can read too.
- Since when?
- It's the stupid hat.
I am telling you, it is totally
blowing my best feature.
- Yeah, company policy is a real drag.
(slow saxophone music)
- Hey twelve o'clock.
- Oh shit, oh shit, okay.
Going in, okay, look.
And you know what,
(crash)
screw company policy.
- Oh my god, you're a whole new man.
- Right?
- Well ladies,
- Oh god.
- Can I get you guys a little
taste of Cherries Jubilee?
No?
Anybody?
Banana Boat?
Four people, four spoons?
Share it in the booth?
- [Judgemental Voice] You suck.
- Do you have a quarter?
- (chuckles)
Are you sure you are tall
enough for that ride?
- Quarter!
- Whoa!
(quarter clinking)
(carnival music)
- Do you need help
getting up little Stevie?
- Whoa! (laughs)
- We're going down!
We're going down!
(elevator falling)
- Yeah, no shit Harrington!
- (screeching)
- Look away! (sighs)
(electronic music)
- Can you redirect your stream please?
(percussive sting)
I hate to break it to you,
but this is not water.
- No, but it's a liquid
and if it comes down to
me drinking that shit
or dying of thirst, I drink.
(glass breaking)
- Jesus Christ
- Ooh
Do you still want to drink that?
(screeching)
- I don't know, but it's possible.
- I'm sorry, is there something you two
would like to share with the class?
(suspenseful beat)
(electronic music)
- I could just take him out.
- Take who out?
- The Russian guard.
(upbeat music)
- And, in the meantime, sling ice cream,
behave, and don't get beat up.
(screaming)
- I'm gonna die in a secret Russian base
with Steve "the Hair" Harrington.
(mimicking trumpet)
- Hey!
Boop.
- We all die my strange
little child friend.
It's just a matter of how, and when.
- [Confused Voice] Wha?
(knife unsheathed)
- Would now be a good time
to tell you that I don't like doctors?
- Whoa! (laughs)
- You broadcast that stupid
spy shit all over town
and we picked it up on our Cerebro
and we cracked it in a day!
A day!
(faint static)
(static)
A day!
(intensified static)
You think you are so smart
but a couple of kids, who
scoop ice cream for a living,
(electronic music)
cracked your code in a day and
now people know you are here.
- Ooh, I just got the chills.
From this float, not your speech.
- (groaning in pain)
- I know his taste is a bit pedestrian
but dingus has other qualities.
- (mimicking trumpet)
(falling over)
(upbeat music)
- I'm Robin
She sounds awesome.
- She is awesome.
(heroic music)